hey what's up guys my name is Samuel
Leeds and I'm just here in Thailand and
I was just thinking isn't it crazy that
when I was at school my aspirations was
to be a Dustbin man or something and all
my teachers by one thought I was stupid
and basically set me up to fail in
business and life and you know I really
thought I was stupid and they don't
teach you at school how to be a business
owner they don't teach you financial
literacy Financial education so I wanted
in this video to share some of the basic
fundamental things that I believe should
be taught in schools that are currently
not you know at the moment I'm actually
building School just built two schools
in Uganda on the basis that the
financial literacy can be in the
curriculum and I wanted to share some of
the key things that I believe should be
taught in schools maybe you missed these
things so I'm going to summarize in this
video so the first thing is passive
income the biggest myth about passive
income is that passive income doesn't
exist it's not as people say oh passive
income what no no no passive income is
not like a scam that gurus talk about to
try and sell you something passive
income is something that pretty much
every successful business in the world
relies on and has any business can
create passive passive income by
systemizing the business having staff
passive income is very very very real I
think the best way to get passive income
is from property investment while
actually is passive income passive
income is money that you make that you
haven't had to work for passive income
is when you get paid while you sleep
right now I'm in Thailand I've been in
Thailand for a week and I'm here for
another week and I'm getting paid my
properties that I own in the UK and all
across the world the rent is still
coming to me even though I'm not in the
country I'm relaxing I'm getting a
sunsan here on the beach in Thailand but
I'm still getting paid because I've got
a business that's set up and systemized
that I get paid whether I'm asleep
whether I'm traveling so passive income
is something that's just never talked
about in school when you're at school
they don't say to you if you need money
for something they don't say we go and
get some passive income son at school
it's go and get a what go and get a job
so we're trained at school to think in
terms of trading our time for money
we're trained at school to be good boys
good girls and and to put our hand up we
want to go to the toilet we're program
to be employees so the first massive
thing is passive income passive income
versus active income rather than trying
to make millions of pounds you just need
to make two three 45,000 a month but it
needs to be passive so figure out how
much money you need to live on and then
absolutely set out to earn that figure
in passive income that's the first thing
second thing is debt so at school we
don't really learn anything about debt
and there's two types of debt there's
good debt and there's bad debt when you
understand good debt you can get very
very very rich and good debt is where
you take out a loan
and that money that you take out that
debt you use to get you rich so an
example would be oh I got a loan for
£15,000 when I was about 19 years old
and that loan I got for £15,000 I used
it as a deposit to buy a house now my
interest on the
£15,000 was only 10% so I'm having to
pay
£1,500 a year I'm having to pay an
interest back to the bank however I'm
now own a house and my profit is way
more than £1,500 a year it's more like
£5,000 a year so with the profit that
I'm getting from that property I'm using
the profit number one to reinvest and to
save and to live off but I'm only using
a small portion of it to service the
debt so debt is your best friend another
thing about debt is debt you can use the
interest payments on the debt is tax
deductible now you need to be a business
to do this but this is why all the
businesses in the world utilize debt and
love debt countries use debt so
understanding the power and the
importance of debt and the difference
between good debt and bad debt third
thing is leverage they don't teach you
about how to leverage I'm not just
talking about leveraging your time I'm
also talking about how to leverage your
money so an example would be that house
that I bought how much did I put down
well I put down nothing but the deposit
was 15,000 the rest was a mortgage the
house that I bought was
£100,000 I still own it today it's in
Block switch on milfield Avenue I bought
it as a teenager now think about this
okay if I bought a house for £100,000
and I put down £15,000 as it happens I
put down nothing but let's say that
£5,000 was my money and then the
mortgage was £85,000 if I'm putting down
£15,000 the house today is worth 250
there's no sponsor to the video but
later this week and next week I'm
spending one day running the property
Investor's crash course tickets are
just1 so whatever you're doing click the
link in the description get booked on
right now let's spend the day together
it all starts at the crash course anyway
back to the video so I put down
£15,000 but now the house has gone up by
£150,000 so I have 10 xed my money have
I 10 xed my money when the house has
only gone up by 150% how about 10x
1,000% in my money because of Leverage
because I'm buying stuff not using my
money as it happens I didn't put down
any money I used the bank's money so I
bought an asset using the bank's money
and the asset that I bought using the
bank's money is not only producing any
positive cash flow every single month
but also it's going up in value and
who's benefiting from the appreciation
me so that's the power of Leverage
That's The Power of good debt bad debt
that's the power of passive income
another thing is asset versus liability
people kids just don't understand they
don't know the difference between an
asset and a liability what is an asset
and what is a liability again a lot of
people think that the house that they
own is an asset so what people do
they'll go to school get a job and then
they'll buy a house and they think that
that house is an asset but it's not and
then they'll pay off the mortgage on the
house and it's a death trap Because by
the time you've actually bought a house
and paid off the mortgage you're
probably 65 years old ready for
retirement on what with a pension so
this whole idea of owning things that
are not assets like owning a car owning
a house that's what people do right they
want to own stuff actually all I want to
own is I want to own assets you know I
didn't buy a house to live in until 2
and a half years ago so I was on M multi
multi multi
multi-millionaire before I actually
bought a house to live in you know why
cuz the house that I live in is not an
asset in fact the house that I live in
is the only house that I own I own a lot
of houses that's not an asset and the
reason it's not an asset is because I
bought it to live in so it's I can't
make money from it I'm not renting it
out it's not putting money in my pocket
if something breaks who has to fix it I
have to fix it it's a liability it loses
money in my pocket now if I've got a
property that I rent out sure I might be
responsible for the repairs depending on
if it's commercial or residential but
but I'm getting money from it cuz I'm
renting it out I'm putting 10% of the
rent aside for repairs I'm putting 10%
aside for management I'm putting 10%
aside for other bits and Bobs and voids
I'm putting maybe 20% aside for the
mortgage payments and then the other 50%
is what is my profit so the definition
of an asset is when you own something or
control something that puts money in
your pocket every single month I don't
want to own a car what if I buy if I
save up for a car put down £20,000 and
buy a car now I've got to pay to
maintain it I got to pay for petrol I
buy a house to live in it it's just the
liability I want to put my money and
invest in things that are assets that
are put it actually cash flowing
positive another massive thing and this
is the final one uh I'm going to mention
but I I could go on I could probably
give a hundred different things that
they should have learned in school about
business about Finance final thing is
sales in life and in business you have
to be able to sell so they don't teach
you this at all in school I've naturally
always been a pretty good sales person
I've been articulate I'm a good
Persuader I'm a good communicator and at
school it was all about can you pass the
test can you memorize the m maical
equations to pass the test I've got ADHD
I've got dyslexia I wasn't very good at
that no one noticed my ability to be
able to communicate to articulate and to
sell that's a skill it's an art and I
think it's something that will the
difference between people that are super
successful and people that struggle a
lot of people that struggle they might
be you know they might be hate students
they might be super academic but if you
can't sell how you going to be able to
do business if you can't sell if you
can't sell an idea if you can't sell a
concept how you going to be able to how
you going to be able to do business so
learn to sell learn to close in Britain
in England it's people don't like
closing for business they're don't like
asking for money they don't oh it's
awkward you have to be able to close
have to be able to sell have to
understand about uh business structure
so there's just just so much it needs to
be a class in school anyway I'm going to
go and dip in the pool now I hope you
enjoyed this video I'll see you guys on
the other side